and now with me you know there's zero
snooze because like I went like four
years ago and I made the day the very
first vr rig came out were a rig for
GoPros we could shoot virtual reality
okay
yeah okay now the next day I had it
literally and I went and shot the very
first underwater swimming with wild
dolphins it's on our website dolphin
project if you watch it on our Facebook
page or through YouTube you get the 360
effect oh cool and it's basically you
swimming with a pot of wild dolphins
it's narrated by E and summer holding
the actor and and I made that for like
10 grand that thing and so the whole
point of my video was like someone like
SeaWorld could spend a million dollars I
mean one the last work of that sold in
captivity was 15 million dollars and
then they had to probably add a build a
30 million dollar tank and then the
upkeep for a million dollars you can
make the most incredible virtual reality
experience or the whole group of people
comes into a theater puts on the goggles
and you're in the wild swimming in a pot
of wild or it'd be incredible
so yeah you can do that we don't need
Dolph we don't need animals in captivity
anymore
what is VR augmented reality 3d you can
do incredible things that are far more
immersive than any experience you're
ever gonna have and is it like so do you
know any statistics on how many
aquariums like aquariums or SeaWorld
locations there are in the in the US
right now I don't and like what's like
what is like the trend with with those
places right now look what's going on
with them I know orcas I would say it's
going down like you know you had the
cove which created this wave of people
now that love dolphins and then you had
a second hit with blackfish so the wave
got bigger yeah and so places that were
new were on the drawing board basically
aren't happening because you know and
then places like a recent place that had
opened up in Arizona there's one company
that owns most of the swim places in
with dolphins in Mexico and they started
infiltrating the US and they it opened
up in Mexico and New Mexico hmm and they
dolphin death and there was just some
local people that were protesting all
the time and then they had another death
and then they had a third death and we
got involved and we actually helped
organize a couple protests right after
the third dolphin death and there was a
huge golf tournament like the one of the
biggest ones in the country and so I
rented a plane with a banner that said
dolphin eros why are three dolphins dead
and we flew it over the golf tournament
it was like something 200,000 people
were on the ground at this Golf Course
watching it was to live on TV and they
actually the TV camera for the ball
thing panned up to the camera panned up
to the plane you see it on TV on the
thing and plus all the local media
covered it no way why it's flying around
another dolphin died and I literally had
to fly in because all the banner planes
were being used for the golf tournament
there was no numbers I had to change the
dolphin number for three to four because
now four Dolphins had died literally as
I'm flying the banner a dolphin died we
had to fly in the number four from
California on another plane and and we
flew the banner the next day at the
tournament wired for dolphins dead and
when that people saw that it just
crushed the place and without an
aquarium within a week they were done
and the Dolphins were shipped off out of
the country Wow
and so there's that kind of groundswell
like you didn't see that twenty years
ago but twenty years ago to just been my
dad and I and we would look like freaks
and they would have played us off as
were some French people but now
literally within days hundreds of people
were in front of that place protesting
and like that's incredible just change
that you know now your dad lives in
Denmark right is there is there a reason
that he lives there or is it like just a
personal thing married a woman from he
married a Danish woman and she for many
years but when they came out probably
for the three years after the code was
out he basically was that because when
you have a movie that wins an Academy
Award like that you're just on the road
it's just week after week somebody's
wanting to screen it somewhere you know
the president of some country or and you
can't say no it's like this could be an
opportunity so he was just on the road
so much she fell
like if she/he wasn't around she'd
rather be back in Denmark than here so
he they've just moved over there okay
now is he is he still how active is he
still with like I was just with him we
were in but right before the quarantine
we were in Bali where we have a dolphin
sanctuary we're preparing two dolphins
that we're gonna attempt to release
there and but now with what's going on
you know he's 80 years old it may not be
safe for him to travel for a couple
years now we'll see what happens but up
until now he travels constantly so when
you went to Bali for example can you
walk me through like what your guys plan
is when you go there and like what steps
you guys take to release these dolphins
when I went to Bali I used I had a TV
show blood dolphins that I was just I
was thinking about doing an episode
there so I went to investigate it
because when you're doing a TV show you
want to find places that are rich where
they have more than one dolphin story
like Solomon's if you watch that episode
there's you know Chris Porter the
dolphin dealer in his facility and I'm
trying to shut him down and get the
dolphin dealers out and then this
village is hunting dolphins and killing
you and I'm trying to stop that and then
there's some guy that had some dolphins
in his backyard and I'm trying to shut
so it it had a lot of stories and angles
and so when you're doing for television
it's helpful to have a lot of things
like that and Indonesia was another
place where there's a village that hunts
dolphins you had a traveling dolphin
circus the last traveling dolphin circus
in the world and then you had tons of
swim places in in Bali and so we had
many things going on and so I decided to
do an episode there and then that led on
to us beginning a campaign for ten years
in Indonesia and so one campaign like I
said was free bali dolphins which is
indonesia indonesia is a massive country
but most of the tourism is based in bali
and so that's where all the swim with
dolphins places are popping up and so i
was like if i can get rid of all of them
here that'll be a massive step there are
other places nindo that we'll work on
but that's a big one
and so that one you know I work with
people that are similar to me I have
people on the ground there that worked
for dolphin project full-time on this
and we would do we created a puppet show
about why dolphins shoot me in captivity
and two of them that traveled
continuously every week in a different
school like around you know hundreds of
schools okay
Bali is one of the capitals right now
for graffiti all the biggest street
artists in the world or I'll stop
passing through Bali it's everywhere and
so I bought thousands of dollars in pain
and gave free paint to any artist that
would do a free Bali dolphin mural and
so they're everywhere you go every city
block there's a massive dolphin free
bali dolphin that it's repetition it's
like like the Obey poster yeah you just
see them so much it's like a repetition
thing so we have so many of these free
bali things it's like you just you see
it block after block I rented every
video monitor at the airport like when
you get off and you're waiting here bags
for 30 minutes they of the screen had an
animation I ran for free don't swim a
captive dolphins in Bali and I just
hammered for years and years and years
and just did press and like eventually
we became partners with the actual
government we have a partnership with
the Forestry Department who manages all
the dolphin issues and so any dolphin
issue that arises in Indonesia they call
us and so years ago I created we call a
camp a limbo lumba we actually found
this National Park where turns out all
of the dolphins in Indonesia are being
alight illegally captured out of this
park and so we built a facility there
that's where the dolphins that will be
released will go to that facility
because chances are other families still
live in that area they're their resident
dolphins but when you see the cove in
Japan those are what's called transient
dolphins those dolphins were swimming
along migrating thousands of miles along
the coastline of Japan they happen
unfortunately the trick come along the
coastline near Taiji and certain places
have residents albans i can hear miami
we have dolphins here that every time
you go in your boat you see the same
developments they just live in this area
they're not ever moving and so there's a
huge resident pod in this area and so we
found the Fisher move able to identify
who was actually catching them and how
he was doing it and what was happening
is the aquariums would call this village
and say we want to buy three dolphins so
the expert fisherman guy he would go out
and catch three dolphins and then he
basically phoned it in as like I
accidentally caught three dolphins in my
fishing net can you call the aquarium to
come rescue them Wow the rescue zone and
they never let him go and that's why
there's about 70 dolphins in captivity
in Indonesia that were all obtained that
way and so what I did is I go I'm like I
built basically the first ever permanent
release facility because we released
almonds in the past but it was always
like a specific dolphin in Brazil
flipper
he's one dolphin we built the facility
we let him go the facility got torn down
because there's many other dolphins in
captivity there I decided to make
something permanent that's been there
for about 10 years then recently in Bali
we've just shut down a hotel called the
Melba hotel and it was a hotel that they
basically had dolphins in the swimming
pool and they built some other pools and
they the guests could swim with dolphins
they were advertising dolphin assisted
therapies they were getting a lot of
families from Russia with autistic kids
paying huge money to swim with the
dolphins and it got sold in the new and
it's been going it's always been a
horrible place but it's recently been
really downhill and so Forestry
Department called us and said look we're
gonna shut these guys down we either you
guys take the dolphins or we'll move
them to another facility we didn't I
didn't have anywhere to take them so I
literally we went we confiscated two of
the dolphins we put them in a swim with
place and we rented some of their pens
with the agreement that we're just going
to keep them there for like two weeks
you can't you just feed them do not let
people sort with them you know these are
our dolphins we're gonna rent your pens
and in two weeks I built a facility up
in North Bali and we
now move the two dolphins that were
still at the hotel and the two dolphins
we had originally confiscated and are
now in that facility and that facility
is going to be we're all dolphins now
when they're confiscated we'll go there
and we determine their if they're
candidates to be released the ones that
can be released we would take and fly
them to our other facility that is an
area where they were captured so that if
they're released they'll be released
there the dolphins that can't be
released like we have one now that were
sure because he has no most of his teeth
were removed and he was in a pool with
no filtration so he's big almost blind
and so he's not a candidate and he can
he's pretty old and so he'll live out
his life at our facility retired and
just living like he doesn't have to do
anything at work for a living or you
know so those facilities that you had
that you have set up those are basically
in the ocean right they're just kind of
like blocked off from there so they
can't the one that is in about the
deepest part is 15 feet and so it's
actually connected to the bottom it's
poles that go down into the sand and
then has netting okay now we have now
that is the Retirement Center is in 60
feet of water and it's 45 feet deep so
it doesn't touch the bottom it hangs
okay and the dolphins the ones that a
retiree will be there forever
now have you ever seen any kind of
problems with these dolphins when you do
release them back into the wild
even if they are resident dolphins do
they ever have any sort of problems like
reconnecting or psychological issues
because I mean these holes are obviously
incredibly all dolphins in captivity any
dolphin can be readapted that means
getting it out of its concrete
chlorinated box and moving it into a sea
pen work and you know the natural
rhythms of the sea and not giving shows
you know we don't feed when we feed our
dolphins it's not at the exact same time
every day
because in real life you're not eating
every day at 4:30 you're eating
sometimes you're missing a meal
sometimes you're eating at 8:30 some
time so that we mix it up so it's more
like real life and so all dolphins can
be moved into a situation where they're
in a natural sea
and those that then we feel are showing
interest in the wild could be moved to
that next stage of possibly being
released and so you're looking for
different things like you know I we've
seen the dolphin before like we we with
this one error Argentina we worked with
our Columbia sorry Stefan yeah we built
a sea pen out in the islands where they
she was captured we moved her from the
tank where she was to the sea pen we
built this huge sea pen off of the beach
we used the beach as one side of it and
then built three squares and she went to
one corner and did the same circles that
she did in her look she was in a little
round pool that she lived her life in
just going in circles and we moved to
his massive pen and she just went to one
corner did circles now is it and so she
was not a candidate to be released
because like it's like prison it's like
some dudes go to prison and after 40
years walk out like nothing to happen
and there's other people go to jail for
two years and they lose it and they're
not the same person ever again and it's
so we do have a protocol for releasing
dolphins but it's really a case-by-case
basis one thing doesn't work for all of
them it's like right so you want to see
things like well slowly sort of
decreasing the amount of like live fish
we're giving them the frozen fish that
they're so dependent on and we'll start
catching like we catch live fish and we
put it into a pen that's hanging in
their pens so they can see the lot of
fish that are interested they know it's
something because we've got it in a pen
so it's special and we get them
interested in and we'll start taking
those fish and throwing them and
hopefully you'll see the dolphins at
first maybe maybe they're not eating
them but they're just having fun
catching them and so you want to start
to see that kind of stuff where some
dolphins just aren't interested and so
they're not going to be candidates right
you know maybe if wild dolphins come
here are they curious or are they
ignoring it or are they seems like
they're sending signals out like you so
you're starting to look for those signs
okay and then as you get you know once
you remove them from where we are now to
like the release facility they're there
were more like a
them through a blinds will set up like a
wall of palm fronds where we can see
through that they can't see us and so we
start to break that connection with man
and start to feed them where they can't
see us and he starts to just slow and
while you're doing that you're walking
are they moving forward is it seem like
they're they're digging this and like
you know you it's obvious some starting
that live fish and boom right away
they're like oh yeah I remember this
like I'm all about this and some are oh
yeah that's amazing and how many how
many dolphins would you estimate that
you guys release a yearly basis or you
know there was a period where we did a
bunch like maybe the 90s and then it
stopped and then like we just helped
they just did a release in South Korea
and but we might add went there a couple
times and they just basically followed
his protocol and we just talked to them
all the time but included no it was like
six dolphins I would say maybe 20 to 25
we've been involved with one way or
another wow that's amazing
so what's it gonna take man what do you
think is the next thing that's gonna
really kind of so the threat is bigger
you know the pushback from the industry
is a lot bigger because there have been
elephant sanctuaries for god knows how
long
thirty years there's even more so than
orcas like Shamu I mean that dolphins
pulling more than that include orcas
that doll orcas a dolphin orcas not a
whale work is the largest member of the
dolphin family so an ork is actually
really so when I say or dolphin okay
well and I think there's actually only
one whale in the United States in
captivity I think it's on the East Coast
somewhere it's just one obscure like
species so basically everything you see
in captivity is a dolphin so I guess my
question was but all things can be moved
all the orphans can be readapted into a
sea pen and retired with dignity and
every animal has that except for marine
mammals every every animals had it for
many many years there's been giraffe
sanctuaries and primate sanctuary
they're all over the world they're there
forever dog cat
everything every animal except for
dolphin is dolphin in the right place
will make more money than any other
animal
[Laughter]